My name is Luisa Neubauer.
I grew up in one of the most
privileged parts of the world,
in Hamburg in Germany.
Growing up, I believed that just
as my parents would take care of me,
governments would take care
of the big problems in the world.
I grew up in a world that told me
that things would just get
better and better
for everyone.
I grew up in a fairy tale.
Part of this fairy tale
is the story of Germany.
Or, to be more precise, the role
of fossil fuels in Germany.
The most obvious impact of fossil fuels
in Germany are soaring emissions.
Germany is the country fourth most
responsible for the climate crisis.
Growing up, however, I didn't know that.
What I knew was this.
Without fossil fuels,
there could never be economic growth.
Without economic growth,
there couldn't be jobs,
there couldn't be wealth,
there couldn't be peace.
So Germany burnt coal, oil and gas
no matter where it was coming from.
This fairy tale isn't unique to Germany.
There are versions of it everywhere.
It took me years to figure out
what was behind this fairy tale.
And once I did,
I became a climate activist.
And together with thousands of others,
we organized the largest
climate protests ever seen.
People then very quickly
started calling us naive
and most found we were so radical.
Yet the only thing we really did
is we broke off the fairy tales
and instead we told the truth.
And because there are
fairy tales everywhere,
telling the truth in the climate crisis
means deconstructing
almost every aspect of it.
People, for instance,
call the climate crisis man-made
and while there were, indeed,
humans behind it,
it's much less man-made
and much more fossil-fuel-made.
It's made possible by the exploitation
of coal, oil and gas
and the profit-driven
economic systems behind it.
Calling the climate crisis man-made
implies it's an accident of human nature,
whereas it's actually
a relatively small group of people
in just a few places around the world,
the fossil fuel industries,
their marketing
and their political supporters.
The fossil fuel industry itself
is also a powerhouse of fairy tales.
Fifty years ago,
they knew that their business
would lead us into a climate disaster.
Back then in the '70s
and the '80s and the '90s,
they had the chance to use that knowledge
to introduce a transition
to renewable energies.
They decided not to.
And instead, they started
telling fairy tales.
They started campaigns to mislead people.
They denied their own climate science
that they did themselves.
And by that, they stole our very first
historic chance to act from us.
So now, for many lives,
it's already too late.
The droughts, the fires and floods
are all happening already in 2022.
No place is safe anymore.
So as the catastrophes
can no longer be denied,
fossil fuel industries have again
started telling new fairy tales,
and this time they present themselves
as part of the solution.
They call it transition.
They promise innovations.
They speak of green growth.
And it sounds wonderful.
It is powerful too.
People really want to believe
that this time,
the Equinors, the Totals, the Shells
and all the others,
this time, they will not steal another
chance to act from us, right?
I would like to believe that too.
But I cannot, for two very simple truths.
Number one,
we do not have time for any more delay.
So whoever tells us that they
will just need some more time
does not understand the very basic logic
of the crisis we are in.
Back in Hamburg when I was in school,
we would get 90 minutes
to finish a math exam.
The fossil fuel industry is, in a way,
taking that very exam right now.
But instead of 90 minutes,
they tell us they will finish
in nine years.
Back in school, that attitude would have
got me failing my assignments.
And the second truth is,
and that's the simple equation
behind the climate crisis,
to limit global heating to 1.5 degrees,
or as close as we can
possibly get to that,
there cannot to be any new
fossil fuel explotation.
No single new project can be constructed.
Yet, as we speak, fossil fuel
industries are planning
let alone 195 new mega-projects,
so-called climate bombs,
each of them emitting more
than one gigaton of CO2.
So as the wind turbines peacefully spin
[in] the TV commercials
they present to us,
fossil fuel industries are expanding
everywhere around the world.
And dancing on our chances to create
anything like a climate justice world.
And after all, this isn't
just about the climate.
Back in Hamburg 30 years ago,
when my grandmother installed
her first solar panel on the roof
and people started talking
of the German “Energiewende,”
it was estimated that Germany
could become energy independent.
It didn't happen.
Why?
Fossil fuel industries went ahead,
lobbied against environmental policies
and together with their
political supporters,
brought the energy transition in Germany
almost to a complete halt.
More than 100,000 jobs were lost
in the solar industry alone,
and as the energy transition slowed down,
Germany imported more fossil fuels
from Russia than any other country.
And now we watch
as Vladimir Putin invades Ukraine.
Made possible by a fossil fuel
war machinery
and paid for by countries like Germany.
Fossil fuels don't only take
lives and livelihoods
and destroy our climate.
They empower autocrats everywhere
to start wars, to threaten democracies,
and to threaten energy systems
in places like Germany
and across the globe onto their knees.
I grew up in a world where fossil fuels,
one way or the other,
would protect our democracies,
our economies and our peace.
Yet the truth is,
in the 21st century,
we need to understand fossil fuels
as a single great threat
to our democracies,
our economies, and our peace.
So what can be the role of fossil fuel
industries in the 21st century?
To the fossil fuel executives, the boards,
the shareholders and everyone attached,
the messages are quite simple:
stop expanding fossil fuels
and stop lying to us about that.
Yet maybe we shouldn't trust
those messages to reach the right people
in the short amount of time we have left.
So there are other messages
for everyone else.
Number one,
if fossil fuel industries don't listen
when people and science tell them
to get out of fossil fuels,
they should not be listened to
when they tell us more fairy tales
about wanting to be part of the solution.
Number two,
if fossil fuel industries don't stop
the destruction of livelihoods,
especially in the most affected places,
they need to be stopped by us.
And number three,
if fossil fuel industries
get to make the rules
about the transition
we so desperately need,
we will not get that transition.
These rules will have
to be made by the people
so they can ever be just
and ever be on time.
And they will have to be
informed by the science
that luckily today tells us
everything that we need to know.
So this is a call
for the people everywhere,
for the normal people
to stop their normal lives
and start beginning
to build a new tomorrow
so that at some point
we can have a new normal again.
That new tomorrow,
it won't be built for those who have
brought us into this entire mess,
whom we have no reason to trust
and who wish to sit
at the same table as we do,
but will never sit at our side.
It will be built for everyone else.
It will put people over profits
and lives over fossil fuels.
It will be just,
and it will be safe after all.
So I'd say, let's get to work.
Thank you.
(Applause)